>> Ryan: BACKUP, MAKE HIM SHOOT.
HERE THEY ARE.
ROCKETS IN TRANSITION, FUTURE
STAR, ELEVATOURT AND
AND SOMETEAM,
ALL 506 MADE THIS SQUAD.
LOOK AT JULIUS RANDLE, JUST A
D ASSIST!
TWO EASY BASKETS HAD
TO COME OVER, HE KIND OF CHECKS-
ON-ONE.
OH!YOUR
TORCH!
JEFF TURNER, THAT IS TAKING IT
RIGHT INTO THE DRILL.
>> Antonio: NICE TO SEE HIM KICK
CED
BY MINNESOTA COMING OUTMUCH HEL
THE
1:20 TO GO IN FIRST QUARTER.
FACU GOT THEIR HAND OUT.
YOU SEE THE DEFENDER WAS TOO FE
TONIGHT. LLIAMS TRAILING AND
KNOCKING IT OFF AND OUT
COACHES. FF THE RIGHT SIDE.
>> Mike:
A LOT OF PEOPLE QUESTION THAT.
BUT I'M TELLING YOU, THIS TEAM
CAN PLAY AND I Y, PUNISH THEM O
END.
>> Mike: AND SCHRODER WITH SOME
BIG BUCKETS SECOND HALF.  GO. S.
OH!
TH RUNWAY.
OH, BABY!
BEHIND HIM, THROWS IT DOWN.BASK.
>> Austin: AND IT'S QUICK